every once in a while it works out that
we don't have an interview scheduled and
I'm going to take that opportunity today
to address a couple of stories that many
in our audience have asked for me to
address the first thing I want to talk
about is this conspiracy theory that the
Clintons Bill Clinton Hillary Clinton
have murdered or ordered killed I don't
think the allegation is they've
personally done it many of their
political opponents inconvenient
individuals who some say were just about
to release some kind of horribly
damaging information about the Clintons
I've not been talking about it but so
many people have asked me to address it
and I'm going to it's entirely
ridiculous and I'll explain why just to
give you a little flavor because if you
haven't been exposed to this it's
actually quite entertaining here's just
30 seconds of one of at this point it
must be a hundred or more videos from
Alex Jones as Infowars about this
conspiracy theory they've been pushing
it check it out before the Clintons left
their governorship in Arkansas more than
a hundred people had been suspiciously
murdered hundreds more died during their
first terms and the scourge continues to
this day
DNC staffer after DNC staffer that
speaks out against election fraud or
leaks information to WikiLeaks ends up
gunned down and the Clinton crime family
and their backers is now in the
spotlight yeah WikiLeaks
I like how he almost sounds like Sean
Connery except less less I'm less
mesmerised by Alex Jones's voice than
Sean Connery's this entire thing makes
no sense and what conspiracists know
what how to do is focus your attention
right the conspiracist will show you
only the coincidences they will concoct
apparent motives but they won't really
ask the big question and the idea is
people who will stand in the way of the
Clinton power grab get killed and there
are websites that maintain lists of all
of these people they range from an
Arkansas lawyer named
Adams to a quote influential Texan named
James bunch who was was found dead and
later it was discovered he had a little
black book not with the names of
influential people from Texas and
Arkansas who visited certain prostitutes
and the idea as well Bill Clinton may
have been one of the names on that list
so he was preemptively killed but the
little black book was found anyway so if
there was a conspiracy to knock the guy
off you might have wanted to take care
of that little black book so let's apply
some basic critical thinking here right
this has nothing to do with Hillary with
whether Hillary Clinton would be a good
president or a bad president she might
be good she might not you might like her
politics you might not this is unrelated
okay first of all the Clintons are one
of the most well known couples in the
world right we're talking about a former
president a former governor a former
first lady a former US senator a former
Secretary of State and a current
presidential candidate that is the
nominee of one of two major American
political parties they've been in
politics it's been I believe 38 years
since Bill Clinton was elected governor
of Arkansas do you realize how many
people they know do you realize how many
people a couple who has been involved in
this level of politics for 38 years how
many people they are connected to
statistically over 38 years many people
are going to die that's number one do
you know the number of people connected
to Jimmy Carter that have died since he
was president of the United States this
argument is not a good argument and we
have to put that aside second and this
is where you really have to think this
through when you look at the total
number of people here that supposedly
were ordered killed by the Clintons is
it 50 people is it a hundred people is
it 200 people depends who you talk to
when you put aside for a second just
like I said the sheer number of people
that the Clintons clearly know when you
look at each of them individually the
risk was not very big to that person
staying alive and outing whatever it was
that they had to out many of these were
you know interns low-level DNC staffers
the risk that someone poses to the
Clinton
even if you believe they had something
juicy is so minor that it is so much
more risky to order them killed because
in the end even if these people who were
just just about ready to expose the evil
Clinton whatever it was that that they
were going to expose you're going to be
able to through the Clinton surrogates
and through friends and corporate media
you're going to be able to attack the
credibility of these individuals we know
that many corporate media outlets are
not even going to pick up these stories
one of the main critiques of the right
is media won't talk about these Clinton
scandals if they don't talk about
Clinton scandals why would you even need
to kill the people who are going to
expose the scandals it doesn't make any
sense it would make no impact and then
lastly for example the instance of
Hillary stole the primaries and the
people that were just about to expose it
ended up dying you've seen how this
happens look at look at what happened in
Florida in the year 2000 look how it
happened in Ohio in the year 2004 voting
irregularities are alleged all the time
sometimes with what we would consider
relatively strong evidence the
investigations dragged on for months or
years very rarely and and really not at
all in presidential races will these
Expos A's from from activists and
insiders actually flip the results so
when you step back for a second this
doesn't make any sense at all and if you
are believing this then what you are
doing is falling prey to a moneymaker
because Alex Jones and Infowars and his
ilk are making a lot of money off of
these theories this stuff will rot your
brain and you have to apply some
critical thinking to it